done and done thin and didn't enter
that's a great song I don't think that
song [ __ ] yeah that was how she
originally started then she got into the
sedge whoo hi guys welcome to this
YouTube video I'm here with the boys of
sorted food except for Jamie cuz he has
wild diarrhea yeah I don't tell them
anything that's alive I'm getting will
CJ okay we're here with Mike berry and
then and we're going to play never have
I ever have you guys ever played this
together before they know how to play
every heart is off-camera over here and
she has some questions that you guys
sent me on Twitter and she's gonna ask
them to us if we have or have not done
these things if we have done them we
drink and then we can all collectively
decide if we'd like to hear the stories
that might be surrounding any of these
drinks okay so here we go remember
ourselves as we are now before we know
all the things that we're about to learn
about each other let's talk about
everything about you two anyway yeah
probably haven't got many secrets well
find out never have I ever got a tattoo
or piercing drunk you might also see how
boring what I see but I wasn't drunk you
got no one sober yes buffering book calm
you could read all about it
well interruption from grace homemaker
that's currently editing this video that
you were watching buffering book by
Hannah Hart if you want to read it you
can go to stores and buy it of course
and read it but if you want to listen to
it you can go to a lovely website called
audible.com audible.com and you can hear
all of the unshared tales of a life
fully loaded buffering book by Hannah
Hart more than that you can hear it for
free if you go to automate out calm
flash grace your first audiobook
download is free and so much spit in my
mouth I don't know why I'm salivating
about audiobooks
oh maybe cuz they're awesome if you
couldn't figure out audible is a great
website for audiobooks they have over
250,000 audio books to choose from two
of those 250,000 audiobooks happen to be
my audiobooks so many options
and it's books up there Q and you can
listen to the entire drunk tattoo story
and its full glory this is the tattoo
now it's almost impossible to read but
you can hear all about how I got that
impossible to read tattoo in the audio
download of buffering book unshared
tales of a life fully loaded by going
idle accomplished grace back to the
video me never have I ever puked in a
stranger's house straight strange oh
yeah oh oh oh look who all the sudden
seems like a classy lady did any of
these moments happen for you guys on the
same night together
momma's two weeks ago what's Wow what
when was that that was a grown adult
Hailey's friends what are what how old
you turned by the birthday party and
it's drunkest I've ever been and I'm
vomited everywhere in the kitchen but I
was back I've been down the sink
registers chocolate shake and then I
went to bathroom and then just did
indignity
you're like I could do some other rooms
I love the sink i watch just a glass of
water I've got it I've got it was behind
guy yeah get great don't know about each
other yeah so fun never have I ever made
out with someone twice my age twice my
current age or twice my age at the time
did the time maths was no mushroom not
shots fired shots fired
never have I ever told then his dish was
nice when it was actually no I was now
we get into the dirt cauliflower rice oh
you don't like cauliflower is what I
don't vote but you told him that you
liked seeing the videos like we want to
film the video where Ben made a choc ice
out of the duck Oh
any of those words it's an ice cream
surrounded with chocolate Oh a chocolate
okay
respected duck and there was a duct mold
and he thought it was an amazing idea I
think it was nice and the ice cream was
nice but then
he coated it in this stuck mold in his
chocolate and it and then painted the
wings gold and it was the most horrific
thing I've ever seen
and he was like he's right here I can't
look him in the eye
well there you go so instead we nibble
from each end yeah and then the most
horrific thing happened at when they
both decided to try it but one when from
the same we did regret that part of it
never have I ever sent a dirty text to
the wrong person
maybe a text to the wrong person like
not necessarily dirty always I won't
incriminating yeah there's always that
one where you're talking about so maybe
you sent with the person you're sending
it to me just chugged your drink
off-camera never I ever shot been to
beer well short on it you put a hole you
like you shake it and put a hole in it
you pop the top and you you don't shake
it you go like this I thought you like
turn it over like this every time and
every time we do it explodes in my face
things that make the Cowboys I know
there's a photo of it just extremely in
my face because I should get never have
I ever gone skinny different I think
that was the same night I shotgun the
big yeah have you guys important in
Vietnam wasn't it yeah in Vietnam it was
a big bay you guys were together I'm
just a dude it shotgunning beer anybody
I'm learning so much never have I ever
made a friend pull a car over so I can
puke on the side of the road oh no it
was amazing yeah maybe had a drink two
weeks ago in Alaska Alaska yeah and I
voted like never eat yellow snow but
what what color is that
mamrie had bad Thai food the night
before and we were about to go trout
fishing never have I ever peed in public
never have I ever been in handcuffs
through criminal purposes story timing
press no I don't think anyone who was
not arrested I'll just leave it never
have I ever had a sexual fantasy about
another youtuber I mean will now Wow Wow
acting that we ran right we keep no we
did and my the writers that always be
good never thought about it oh so you
guys did it for a video didn't do it in
life when you're drunk and you realize
like oh that pad guys still fine
you drip lasagna on the floor of our
hotel room and ate it straight off never
have I ever walked in on anyone I guess
doing it is doing sex yeah doing sex
doing the that doing the sex I haven't
worked at home I think yeah I like that
you were called it as if it was a fond
memory yeah well you're just gonna say
names of real people with real knives oh
oh I went to Mexico
locker door thank you guys for playing
never have I ever always good fun I
think it was a very educational
experience like you maimry hart for
running the game and make sure you guys
go check out sorted food they have a
really amazing series fridge cam that's
really fun and funny and silly and
they're just great guys so go check out
their YouTube channel all the links will
be in the description box below thanks
for watching I don't know
[Music]
the car